et notre invité politique ce matin ces
manuels dont par bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur et le député la
france insoumise des bouches-du-rhône et
on va parler évidemment ce qui s'est
passé cette semaine à l'assemblée
d'abord eric coquerel qui a donc été élu
hier à la tête de la prestigieuse
commission des finances le rassemblement
national qui est premier groupe
d'opposition en termes de nombre de
députés dénoncent une piraterie que leur
répondez vous d'abord c'est une très
bonne nouvelle l'élection de eric
coquerel à la tête de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale c'est
justement la démonstration que
contrairement à ce que dit le
rassemblement national
la première force d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale c'est la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale
canton rassemblement national il a l'air
d'ignorer le fait que quand on est
quatre groupes qui nous mettons d'accord
sur une candidature commune nous sommes
numériquement beaucoup plus important en
terme de nombre de députés que le nombre
de députés du rassemblement national et
donc la deuxième le deuxième
enseignement de cette élection c'est
contrairement à ce qu'on dit depuis dix
jours ce qu'on a dit pendant la campagne
électorale en tout cas qu'un certain
nombre de personnes ont dit la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale
elle est unie elle est regroupée à la
gîte concert à l'assemblée nationale
elle propose des candidatures communes
et l'élection d'eric coquerel on est le
symbole est ce qu'on voit ci n'ont pas
crié
à la france est soumise qui ont dénoncé
un de la nuque d'ailleurs en passe de la
france assure me olivier fois rossi a
été dénoncé un poteau une alliance entre
la droite et l'extrême droite vous avez
un peu plus est trop tôt à non pas du
tout parce que nous avons effectivement
dénoncer cela et ça a été une réalité
sur le début de la semaine c'est-à-dire
comptes ont été
désignés la présidence de l'assemblée
nationale les membres du bureau de
l'assemblée nationale où clairement ce
qu'il est apparu c'est que le
rassemblement national des républicains
et la république en marche la majorité
s'étaient mis d'accord pour se répartir
les responsabilités au sein du bureau de
l'assemblée nationale ce qui fait que
avait eu la nuit pas de vice président
oui bien sûr mais je rentre un peu dans
les détails ce président si on avait
cherché le strict respect
proportionnelle comme ça se fait
traditionnellement à l'assemblée
nationale nous nous aurions dû avoir le
droit bien sûr à ses deux vice
présidents mais également un poste de
questeur or sur le vote sur la question
et à trois questeurs le troisième
questeur revient traditionnellement
l'opposition clairement les républicains
et la république en mars s'étaient mis
d'accord ils ont même déposé un bulletin
doit les
bas manifestement je sais pas si c'est
l'opposition mais une opposition
traditionnellement c'est pas
l'opposition que ceux choisis le pouvoir
quand on est une véritable opposition
c'est pas la majorité qui détermine qui
est son opposition sinon c'est une
opposition qui est une opposition pas
très sérieuse
pas de vice présidents par exemple oui
oui je suis conscient ils ont abandonné
cette vice-présidence pour avoir cette
question mais si vous faites la stricte
répartition de ce que chacune chacun
c'est un peu technique peut-être pour
ceux qui nous écoutent devrait avoir au
respect de la proportionnelle c'est
traditionnellement comme ça que ça se
fait la nouvelle union populaire devait
disposer de deux vice présidences et
dans une question d'une questure et
clairement il ya eu un accord entre la
droite et l'extrême droite pour sur le
dos de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale se répartir les
différentes responsabilités au bureau ça
va changer
vous souhaitez en faire cette option
finance mais d'abord contrairement à ce
que j'ai entendu pendant la campagne on
va dire de de l'élection de ce président
de la commission des finances c'est pas
un objet qui permet de lancer des
vendettas personnelles ou je ne sais
quoi c'est pas du tout notre état
d'esprit
évidemment écouter eric coquerel et
président de cette commission elle
revient traditionnellement à
l'opposition c'est une commission qui
est notamment en charge d'examiner sur
les aspects budgétaires le fait que les
différentes propositions de loi bon bah
sont sérieuses d'un point de vue
budgétaire on va faire ce travail après
il est vrai ça on ne s'en cache pas que
si il faut lancer des initiatives des
commissions d enquête sur les questions
de fraude et d'évasion fiscale nous le
ferons mais nous ferons de manière
collective pas en allant chercher
des des vendettas personnelles c'est pas
du tout notre état d'esprit mais je
crois que les françaises et les français
sont intéressés par le fait que ya une
action vigoureuse à l'assemblée
nationale pour lutter contre la fraude
et l'évasion fiscale donc de ce point de
vue là si certains sont inquiets par le
fait qu'on le fasse ils ont raison
d'être inquiet parce qu'on va le faire
dominique était à votre place il ya
quelques instants disait considérant
comme vous que la droite et la
république en marché renaissance sont de
droite que du coup la droite est
largement majoritaire cette commission
des finances et du coup eric coquerel va
devoir porter un budget de droite quand
vous allez faire non mais le président
de la commission des finances il porte
pas un budget mais là où bien aux lire
sa raison le
président l'ensemble des membres de
cette commission des finances est donc
comment ça va se passer lors du débat du
budget eh bien il fera ce travail de
manière c est à dire que à la fin il y
aura une décision de cette commission
est peut-être que cette décision nous ne
serons pas d'accord avec tous les
éléments de cette décision mais ça s'est
toujours produit comme ça
traditionnellement le président de cette
commission est membre de l'opposition
alors que les positions n'est pas
majoritaire dans la commission donc on
fera comme ça se faisait avant il n'y a
pas de raison de changer ça bon il n'y a
pas de raison de faire autrement que que
ce qu'on faisait avant un mot sur la sur
eric coquerel lui-même puisque vous avez
sans doute entendu et r1 rokhaya diallo
qui dit avoir plusieurs sources au sein
de la france en sont mises parler du
comportement inapproprié d'eric coquerel
avec les femmes elle se dit du coup sûr
prises par votre choix de le nommer à la
commission des finances est ce que vous
aviez des informations sur un
comportement inapproprié
cochrane n'ont aucunement hilliard
d'ailleurs vous savez on a une cellule
en charge des violences sexistes et
sexuelles au sein de la france insoumise
cette cellule a publié un communiqué
hier soir disant les choses de manière
très claire et factuel il n'ira et aucun
signalement témoignages qui a été
adressé à cette cellule donc jamais rien
entendu jamais parlé de ça mais je je je
lis comme tout le monde les rumeurs sur
les réseaux sociaux et là je jeûne
observé que ces rumeurs sont relayées
dans la presse jeudi que le sujet de la
lutte contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles est un sujet trop sérieux pour
être livré uniquement aux rumeurs qui
circulent sur les réseaux sociaux sans
aucun témoignage concret donc les choses
elles sont très claires si madame
rokhaya diallo dispose de témoignages de
personnes qui mettent en cause telle ou
telle personne pas uniquement ce député
mais telle ou telle personne membre de
la france a soumis jeudi a dressé les a
au comité de lutte contre les violences
sexistes et sexuelles qui a été mis en
place au sein de la france insoumis 6 et
des acteurs répréhensible a dressé les à
la justice
existe
des fins je sais pas je parle pas de ce
sujet spécifique de manière générale on
a toujours fonctionné de cette manière
et on a une attention très importante à
ces questions qui sont des questions
très sensibles de lutte contre les gens
c'est que si ces sexuelle je rappelle
quand même ici que il ya quelques mois
nous avons en trois jours suite à des
signalements qui avaient été adressées à
cette cellule décidé qu'un candidat qui
était candidat aux élections
législatives ne l'était plus donc on ne
peut pas de deux procès sur ce sujet
mais attention au temps on est très
sérieux sur ce sujet autant justement
parce qu'on est très sérieux sur ce
sujet ça peut pas être les rumeurs sur
les réseaux sociaux sans aucun signe
témoignage concret aucune preuve aucun
aucun signalement qui fasse office
d'information donc là il faut être un
peu sérieux sur le sujet parce que sinon
ça veut dire qu'il ya aussi des
personnes qui sont livrés en quelque
sorte à la vente des réseaux sociaux
alors que ça ne s'appuient pas sur des
témoignages concrets sénatrice qui prône
une
personne à l'opposition elle vous
demande des clarifications qu'est ce que
vous lui dites est ce que ça peut
fragiliser la nuque g2 les
clarifications elles ont été donné il y
à une cellule cette cellule a fait un
communiqué il n'y a aucun témoignage qui
n'a jamais été adressées à cette cellule
points un mot sur ce qui s'est passé
encore cette semaine à l'assemblée
nationale et on a vu notamment lors de
l'élection à la présidence les actions
dia lebron pirée 1 débutait la france
est soumise mais by a refusé de serrer
la main des députés du rassemblement
national
non pas du tout je pense que chacune
chacun se comporte comme il le souhaite
et je pense que s'il ya quelque chose
qui était choquant cette semaine à
l'assemblée nationale
c'est davantage les propos qui ont été
tenus par le doyen d'âge qui a présidé
la séance d'ouverture
plutôt que le fait que telle ou telle
personne n'ait pas voulu
exactement dix ans que à sa connaissance
il n'y avait pas eu de crime de l'aurès
bon il me semble que
il a dit ensuite dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée nationale quand il a été
interrogé sur ces propos or il me semble
que c'est un petit peu plus choquant que
le fait de savoir si telle ou telle
personne doit serrer la main à telle ou
telle personne voilà donc je pense qu'il
faut être un petit peu raisonnable quand
même
volonté de rassemblement national de
montrer qu'il est un parti responsable
qu'il est un parti et constructif et que
du coup vous n'êtes pas en train de
perdre en quelque sorte la bataille de
l'image la bataille de l'opposition
responsable mais non enfin je veux dire
nous nous nous ne nous faisons pas nous
sommes une formation politique
d'opposition et manuel macro nous
l'avons dit pendant la campagne
électorale nous avons dit nous voulons
être idiot pour combattre le programme
politique des manuels macro et pour
porter un programme politique différent
de manière majoritaire nous sommes pas
majoritaires nous en prenons acte donc
nous sommes une formation politique
d'opposition si le rassemblement
national a décidé d'abandonner une
position d'opposition et de commencer
comme il l'a fait cette semaine des
petits arrangements avec le pouvoir
c'est son problème mais en ce qui nous
concerne nous sommes loyaux droits dans
nos bottes et nos portes ont la parole
des électrices et des électeurs
vous êtes prêt une opposition
constructive mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire une opposition frontale ou une
opposition qui la déteste
de loi qui viennent je me plais projet
de loi qui viennent du gouvernement des
propositions à quillan de la majorité
présidentielle vous pourrez les voir
tomber si ça va dans le bon sens il ya
pas de raison de ne pas aller voter nous
l'avons toujours fait mais on peut tout
à fait être constructif et frontale un
frontal compte les projets qui sont
porteurs porté par emmanuel macro ne
nous conviennent pas et oui nous serons
frontale quand emmanuel bacrot et sa
majorité vont décider de reporter l'âge
de départ à la retraite à 65 ans je le
dis ici peut s'attendre de ne pas une
opposition très frontal c'est clair mais
si emmanuel macron décide enfin par
exemple 2d conjugue alizés l'allocation
adulte handicapé c'est une proposition
politique que nous portons dans notre
programme nous la voterons avec plaisir
donc vous voyez il n'y a pas d'un côté
les constructif et de l'autre les
frontales par contre si le rassemblement
national a décidé peu à peu de commencé
à s'arranger avec le pouvoir c'est son
problème mais je suis pas sûr que ses
électrices et électeurs sont ravis
bah écoutez cette semaine je vous en ai
donné une première démonstration sur les
responsabilités au sein de l'assemblée
nationale et puis on verra la semaine
prochaine c'est à dire madame bonne
viande mercredi prochain s'exprimer
devant l'assemblée nationale premier
élément est ce qu'il y aura un vote de
confiance ou pas vous le demandez encore
alarmant mais c'est pas juste nous
qu'ils dénoncent et franchit pas il me
semble c'est le minimum du respect qu'on
doit aux électrices et aux électeurs ils
ont voté aux élections législatives ils
ont fait le choix de ne pas donné de
majorité absolue à emmanuel macron donc
madame madame bornes travail a essayé de
constituer une majorité elle doit venir
devant l'assemblée nationale elle doit
présenter sa feuille de route et il doit
y avoir un vote de confiance soit elle a
la confiance et elle peut travailler et
soit elle n'a pas la confiance et dans
ce cas là elle doit démissionner et un
autre gouvernement doit être mise en
place c'est le respect élémentaire de la
démocratie mais est ce que votre vote de
confiance il tiendra compte des propos
d'elisabeth bornes et selon la vision
qu'elle porte question la teneur
générale vous pourriez la beauté
son propos quel que soit son discours
voilà battrait pas écouté soyons pas de
mauvaise foi elle a déjà dit qu'elle
était sa free d'hôtes
si madame banon vient devant l'assemblée
nationale est dit finalement je ne vais
pas reporter l'âge de départ à la
retraite je vais augmenter le smic je
vais m'engager sur un blocage des prix
sur les produits de première nécessité
puisque le président de la république
emmanuel macron a dit lui même qu'il y
avait des profiteurs de guerre cette
semaine donc ça veut dire qu'à un moment
il faut faire quelque chose bon si elles
disent ah ah oui là pas de problème mais
vous savez très bien qu'elle ne va pas
dire ça donc il faut pas faire semblant
donc elisabeth bandai va venir elle va
tenir son discours elle va présenter sa
feuille de route et c'est une feuille de
route dans laquelle je le sais déjà nous
ne pourrons pas nous retrouver et donc à
partir de ce moment là clairement nous
ne voterons pas la confiance pour pour
elisabeth bande et si elisabeth bonne
décide de ne pas présenter demandé le
vote de confiance il y aura une motion
de censure pour que les membres de
l'assemblée nationale puisse se
prononcer sur le sujet et puisque notre
sujet c'est tel rassemblement national à
cette occasion on verra ce que fera le
rassemblement national
qu'il ne présenterait pas
vous ne posiez la question de savoir la
houlette patronat et vous savez très
bien qu'on ne voit trompa votre
proposer un projet qu'il vaut mais ils
ont l'air tout à fait la possibilité
d'en déposer une s'ils le souhaitent
mais manifestement ils n'ont pas prévu
de le faire donc puisque votre question
c'était en quoi vous pouvez dire qu'il
ya des arrangements entre la majorité et
le rassemblement national je vous en
mets un première arrangements sur la
table la motion de censure la france
je pense qu'elle sera commune à la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale nous demandent en tout cas deux
concerts que madame bande demande la
confiance si madame bornes ne demande
pas la confiance je pense que nous
déposerons deux concerts une motion de
censure
c'est luis et les échanges que nous
avons eus cette semaine et des
consultations avec les groupes
parlementaires savent déjà ce qu'on vous
dit que c'est une bonne chose que les
abeilles on est consulté toute la
semaine les groupes d'opposition c'est
une normale c'est ni une bonne ni une
mauvaise c'est normal qu'elle le fasse
elle essaye de constituer une majorité
pourrait s'avérer utile pour vous ces
consultations bah pas en ce qui nous
concerne puisque
elle a dit aussi les choses précisément
elle a dit le canevas général ça reste
le projet présidentiel d'emmanuel macro
donc à partir de ce moment là comme je
le disais tout à l'heure on ne va pas se
retrouver dans ce dans ce projet c'est
pas vrai donc mais après c'est légitime
c'est républicain qu'est le solliciter
qui consultent les différents groupes
d'opposition pour savoir ce qu'elles ont
à dire moi j'ai rien à redire sur le
sujet maintenant si à la fin madame ben
10 bon finalement je ne vais pas avoir
de majorité dont je ne vais pas donner
la confiance demander la confiance là ça
pose un problème parce que le principe
d'une élection c'est qu'on se présente
pas uniquement quand on est sûr de
gagner sinon c'est plus tout à fait une
élection une élection pouvait laganière
pourrait la perdre donc madame brunel
doit venir devant l'assemblée elle doit
prendre un peu ses responsabilités elle
doit bien est ce que il ya une majorité
de l'assemblée nationale qui est
d'accord avec le fait que je mette en
place mon programme était l'objectif de
ces consultations pour vous sachant qu
emmanuel macron a dit que lui c'était
que la coalition haye du parti
communiste république donc en excluant
la france un soliste mais bon d'abord je
sais qu'elle est la tactique des manuels
macro et la grossièreté d'ailleurs de
cette tactique n'a échappé à personne
c'est à dire d'essayer de fracturer la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale et de dire qu'ils auraient les
gens raisonnables et légendes et
raisonnable mais il faut écouter ce
qu'ont dit les autres membres de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale si vous voulez je suis un
déraisonnable je suis dans le camp
d'eads est raisonnable mais que dit
andré chassaigne le président du groupe
communiste et dit nous n'acceptons pas
que vous triez entre nous que dit
olivier faur que dit julien billot ils
disent la même chose donc ça sert à rien
c'est vain d'essayer de 2,2 d'enfoncer
descoings entre nous nous agissons de
concert nous avons présenté des
candidats communs nous présenterons
d'hommes sans doute et nous voterons la
même chose sur la confiance nous allons
présenter des propositions de loi
commune sur la constitutionnalisation de
l'ibg sur le pouvoir d'achat donc nous
avons six cent cinquante propositions
communes nous avons un intergroupe qui
se réunit chaque semaine voilà ce que je
dis à emmanuel macron votre tentative de
nous diviser evene vous n'y parviendrez
pas donc nous allons agir de concert et
nous sommes votre opposition principal à
l'assemblée nationale
même à conques et a annoncé un nouveau
gouvernement pour le début du mois de
juillet donc pour les prochains jours
damien abad peut figurer dans ce
gouvernement pour vous je pense qu'au vu
des différents témoignages qui ont été
publiés dans la presse et qui compta
saint jehan tant qu'ils les contestent
il ya un certain nombre de témoignages y
en a pas car il y en a plusieurs il me
semble que le signal qu'il faudrait
donner pour montrer qu'on entend qu'on
écoute et qu'on respecte la parole de
ces femmes se seraient effectivement que
monsieur havane ne soit pas membre de ce
gouvernement je pense que ce serait la
solution la plus raisonnable mais ça
veut dire j'espère revenir à ce qu'on
disait au début de cette interview
conseil des témoignages qui sont
contraires échos
mais s'il y avait plusieurs témoignages
circonstanciés
crédible et sérieux comme c'est
manifestement le cas dans la sphère de
damien abad où il faut pas faire deux
poids deux mesures mais vous savez très
bien que pour l'instant là excusez moi
mais vous mettez sur le même plan de
choses qui nous allons je dis oui mais
je me permets de préciser que ces deux
éléments n'ont aucun rapport c'est à
dire vous avez d'un côté un ministre qui
est l'objet d'un certain nombre de
témoignages sérieux de l'autre côté vous
avez juste une rumeur sur les réseaux
sociaux de quelqu'un qui dit que
quelqu'un lui a dit que quelqu'un lui a
dit que quelqu'un lui a dit vous pouvez
pas comparer ces deux aspects là et il
faut faire attention à ce sujet il est
trop sérieux pour qu'on confonde tout
qu'on mélange tout il ya deux situations
qui sont tout à fait différentes
mémoires pour le reste j'ai jamais fait
deux poids deux mesures donc s'il y
avait une situation similaire elles
devraient être traités de la même
manière que ce soit un bond de
l'opposition un monde de la majorité et
c'est très clair sur les textes que vous
allez examiner un texte pouvoir d'achat
qui va être parmi les premiers texte
examiné à l'assemblée on connaît déjà
certaines mesures notamment une aide
pour les plus modestes lunettes de son
rôle dans l'indexation des pensions de
retraite
sur l'inflation est ce que ce sont des
mesures que vous allez soutenir mais les
mesures qui permettent de renforcer le
pouvoir d'achat des françaises et des
français bien évidemment où je vais les
soutenir mais il suffit pas qu'ils aient
marqué pouvoir d'achat dont le titre du
projet de loi pour que ça soit une bonne
chose par exemple vous donne un exemple
on a annoncé cette semaine je crois que
c'est bruno le maire qui a fait cette
annonce qu' on allait limiter
l'augmentation des loyers à 3 5% et dans
le même temps en aller
augmenter les appels de 3 5% si vous
mettez ces deux mesures ensemble à la
fois ça se traduit par une perte de
pouvoir d'achat puisque les loyers vont
augmenter en moyenne on prend en moyenne
de 270 euros et que les apl vont
augmenter de son doute 150 ou 180 euros
là je parle le parent donc et ça par
exemple c'est pas parce que ça s'appelle
pouvoir d'achat qu'à la fin ça se
traduit par une augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat c'est précisément l'un verse
donc moi j'attends de voir précisément
keira dans ce projet de loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat s'il ya des éléments qui
vont dans le bon sens nous voterons
faveur des éléments qui vont dans le bon
sens et s'il ya des éléments qui vont
pas dans le bon sens nous voterons
contre les éléments qui vont pas dans le
bon sens c'est aussi simple que ça donc
ya pas de dogmatisme il ya juste une
demande qu'on coup sache précisément de
quoi on parle avant que nous disent vous
allez voter pour parce que ça s'appelle
pouvoir d'achat ballon dès fois ça
s'appelle pouvoir d'achat mais ça fait
leur verse donc je répondrais
précisément quand on aura le projet de
loi complet ou michel edouard leclerc à
hem rila d'hier il aimerait une
commission d' enquête sur l'inflation
après des hausses de prix suspecte c'est
ce qui est ce que vous allez vous
l'apporté cette commission denquête faut
qu'on en discute ensemble mais en tout
cas ça me paraît être une très bonne
idée parce que clairement michel edouard
leclerc qui jusqu'à preuve du contraire
n'est pas membre de la france a soumises
rejoint
notre diagnostic
c'est à dire que contrairement à ce
qu'on entend depuis plusieurs semaines
et plusieurs mois les hausses de prix
sur le carburant sur les produits de
première nécessité notamment les
produits alimentaires ne sont pas dus
qu'à la guerre en ukraine ne sont pas du
carca des éléments de la conjoncture
internationale mais son dû de manière
très importante et sans doute essentiel
à des logiques spéculatives sur les
marchés exemple on a appris qu'au mois
de mai sur le marché du blé la baule la
bourse de paris il y avait à peu près 70
% des achats qui était l'objet de
spéculateurs et clairement ce qui est en
train de se passer c'est qu'il ya un
certain nombre d'acteurs économiques qui
parient sur la hausse des prix pour
prendre des positions se disant ensuite
on pourra revendre nos positions un peu
plus tard puisque les prix seront plus
importants et on en mettra plein les
poches de la même manière vous avez des
entreprises comme total par exemple qui
ont généré des dividendes qui sont des
dividendes exceptionnels vous pouvez pas
avoir d'un côté les français qui tient
la langue pour finir les fins de mois
qui n'arrivent plus à faire le plein qui
n'arrive plus à manger à leur faim et de
l'autre côté des grandes entreprises qui
s'en mettent plein les poches donc non
seulement faut avoir cette commission
enquête mais ensuite je suis allé porter
finalement je souhaite qu'on le fasse la
france il trouva en parler
collectivement et pour le reste suit pas
seulement d'avoir une commission
denquête il faut des actes une taxation
particulière et spécial sur les
dividendes qui ont été générés et 2 des
mesures d'encadrement et de blocage des
prix si on fait pas ça ça veut dire
qu'on accepte l'idée soit que d'un côté
certains s'en mettre plein les poches
soit encore pire que ce soit le budget
de l'état par des chèques qui viennent
contribuer d'une certaine manière à
alimenter les dividendes des
actionnaires bas ça ça peut pas être une
solution raisonnable le premier
but des chiffres de l'épidémie qui
aurait floué dans le pays il faut
prolonger l'état d'urgence non je ne
crois pas je pense que ça n'a servi à
rien l'état d'urgence sanitaire et je
crois qu'à force de prolonger cet état
d'urgence sanitaire c'est devenu
quasiment un état normal et je trouve
que c'est très inquiétant d'un point de
vue du respect des libertés
individuelles
duel s'il ya effectivement une
recrudescence des contaminations il faut
peut-être sans doute renforcer le
travail de sensibilisation dire que
d'abord faire la vérité c'est dire
quelles sont ses chiffres pour que un
certain nombre de personnes prennent
leurs responsabilités dans les
transports publics dans des endroits où
on est assez remettre peut-être le match
je dis pas qu'il faut le rendre
obligatoire mais peut-être avoir une
action de sensibilisation sur sur sur le
sujet bon voila mais l'état d'urgence
sanitaire non personnellement je suis
pas favorable à sa reconduction pour un
dernier mot sur l'avenir de la france
insoumise un sens jean luc mélenchon est
ce que la france insoumise va devoir se
recomposer est ce que vous vous
souhaitez que la nu remplacer à terme la
france en sont alors d'avoir s'est passé
aujourd'hui qu'au chili les plus député
à l'assemblée nationale salon leader de
votre part trouve mais vous allez voir
mais enfin et jean luc mélenchon il n'a
jamais prétendu qu'il allait prendre sa
retraite politique d'argent ceux qui
ceux qui veulent mettre sur les communes
au chaud à la retraite n'y arriveront
pas donc j'en le cochon il travaille et
il aura hélas choi l'a dit lui même je
change de poste de combat donc il aura
un autre poste de combat c'est pas à
l'assemblée nationale dont d'abord s'est
passé
peut-être qu'il aura on est en train
d'en discuter peut-être qu'il aura un
rôle d'animation dans le mouvement
peut-être qui prendra en charge un
certain nombre de fonctions au sein de
notre mouvement bon tout ça c'est des
éléments
mais peu mais pas forcément à la tête
nous verrons nous allons en parler et il
nous faut un petit peu de temps vous
soyez passion pour l'instant les gens
les colons choix irréfléchi justement à
tout ça mais il conservera bien
évidemment un rôle et pour le reste la
france a soumis ce continuera à exister
mais ça restera une composante de la
nuit et personnellement je suis tout à
fait favorable à ce que la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale
continue à exister et continue à
travailler de concert continue à
approfondir les discussions que nous
avons eues pendant la campagne parce que
je pense que nous avons été portés par
les électrices et des électeurs qui a eu
une dynamique autour de cette dynamique
de rassemblement et je pense qu'il faut
qu'elles se poursuivent
[Musique]